hey thank you oh first of all we made it
we made it through 2020.
we made it through that endurance test
that we didn't know we signed up for
it's like we were going about
a year and then we all got transported
to hell and hell was like hey
just got to do this academic decathlon
here in hell
gotta do this endurance test have fun
but i have to thank you all
and i hope this comes across as genuine
you know like because
if i had a nickel for every time i meant
something genuine
and people took it otherwise because the
situation is and was i'm a person on
youtube who talks about movies
generally speaking new movies and i talk
about these new movies on my channel
that's what i do
that's what my channel does my chat well
it's a little redundant my channel does
because i do
you get it and then one day it was like
no more new movies
have fun and that's not even a
specifically me thing or youtube thing a
lot of people ran
into that a lot of people ran into what
am i gonna do in 2020. so the situation
as it was for me in my corner of reality
was well people are either gonna come
and hear me talk about whatever because
they'd like
seeing my face and hearing my voice talk
about what i want to talk about
or they come for information about new
movies and my channel is just going to
choke and die
and my channel survived 2020 because you
all apparently just like coming here
and hearing me talk about things i like
talking about i mean not everybody sure
there's a number of people
who come for information on the new
movie releases
but there's a solid number of you who
came back you kept coming back to my
channel
and clicking on my videos because
whatever your reason
that's why i just have to thank you all
and i think that's important i think
it's important for people to recognize
when they should thank people and thank
people like if i didn't give you a
thank you at the end of this year for
keeping my channel alive
i just wouldn't feel right about it i'd
feel like a [ __ ] again take that in the
sincerest way possible
um my channel is still alive because of
you and i go on to 2021
because of you and that's just that's a
fact i know at this point this time i'd
usually have a top 10
best movies of the year list and the top
10 worst movies at the year list but the
fact is
i didn't watch enough new content to do
those videos
i mean i just didn't when i think of the
top 10 best movies of the year i
again i'm like yeah speed was great so i
have all these other videos
in my head as the enjoyable videos i did
this year and it's just
let's all agree it was just a weird
different year i'm just completely
unqualified to give my top 10 best and
worst of the year list
so it's just instead of those videos you
get a thank you
i feel like that's more important
however let's reminisce on the year and
the things
that happened on my channel in the year
and where i just kind of was
mentally speaking when i did this and
that and first of all i i feel like i
need to
speak to my fellow type b personality
types out there and maybe some type a
folks who could better understand my
fellow type b personality folks yeah
that was the hardest thing because
in my channel there's a rotation but
there's also a consistency
i know that every weekend there's going
to be a new movie like one movie minimum
two movies probably so there's a couple
videos that i know
on a weekly basis i'm going to do and
that just kind of keeps the consistency
going it keeps the machine turning and
anything i want to do
in between that i can do but i can rely
on that weekly momentum to happen
because the universe just kind of says
hey here are a couple of new movie
releases and i
do reviews on those movie releases but
at a point in this year
nope you no longer have that you just
kind of got to do it yourself and that
for me was hard i know i
come across as this go-getter so i've
heard i heard i come across as a person
with the plan you know like oh hey yeah
we got the plan
that's not me that's type a i'm type b
as [ __ ]
so yeah so without that guaranteed
momentum i had to
think of like all right well what videos
do i want to do this week which sounds
really easy
but when you're me it's not as easy so
that was a hurdle i suppose that was
adapt to survive that's life which is
why mandalorian being a weekly show and
the boys before mandalorian
a weekly show i did weekly videos on
that week's episode i did weekly videos
on the episodes for those shows because
it
gave me that feeling of that guardrail
being back up video game reviews had to
be stepped up
i mean i knew i'd be doing more video
game reviews i don't actually
logistically know if i did
more video game reviews this year i feel
like i did sure regardless i was like
i can't rely on trailers of video games
anymore i'm gonna i'm gonna need to pull
some game footage and capture
some gameplay footage that i actually do
also special thank you to jake baldino
for giving my channel a little bit of
love
when i first started reviewing more
games this year
you know he was like oh yeah jeremy
johns he's been doing good and
you know he's a good dude and he's a
he's just a genuine
soul on youtube this minefield of
youtube
really that's all you can ask for but
also there are a couple of fun things i
did this year
like you know the the mere universe
review it was actually okay story time
if we're gonna break first story time
for a second here's
how that happened it was like the night
before april fool's day and i was like
oh my gosh tomorrow's april fool's day
i should totally do something you know
like something something fun
something different my first reaction
was okay review a bad movie like it's
good
but i was gonna like super troll not
even i was gonna pull a bad movie
and not let anyone know that i actually
thought it was a bad movie and review it
like it was a good movie
and then i was like well they have to
know i'm bullshitting because
at that point that's just credibility i
mean there have been bad movies like bad
movies that i've given
positive reviews for but it's because i
enjoyed myself in them so there's still
honesty there let's just take a bad
movie and say it's good
knowing it's bad there's just that's not
a real representation of my
of my headspace so i didn't want anyone
to walk away from that review going oh
hey
he actually thinks this is a good movie
me being a star trek fan okay
mirror universe that was the logical
thing we'll have mirror universe jeremy
and also me being a huge twilight zone
fan twilight zone's one of the best
shows ever made
so is star trek the next generation but
mirror universe is from the original
star trek and deep space nine point is
okay so the intro
in this rod sterling kind of way though
to this day i
don't know i i still don't have a
definite answer as to whether or not i'm
channeling
rod sterling or i'm channeling carl
sagan
probably both so when i listen to it
sometimes i'm like rod sterling and
other times i'm like carl zagan
i think the voice changes as i'm doing
it i don't know i just go where my brain
takes me what can i say and of course
you know batman and robin that's the
logical choice that's the easy like yup
bad movie and we'll say it's good
but then it was gonna obviously say it
was good when it was bad you know like
all the acting is so great
you know like clearly it was gonna be
fake but then at the last moment i got
this
neat idea to talk about the things in
the movie in a positive light that could
be argued
to be positive like you know like the
bat nipples the bat nipples on these
suits and they hearken back they throw
back
to old greek gods and that's the reason
for the suits and the perfect body
structure and the bat nipples
and that really brings it home like that
is the reason the bat nipples are on the
bat suit
so i got this more creative idea i think
it's a more interesting idea to argue
for batman and robin in a way that's
legit like the things that i talk about
in that review in a positive light
are actually things in the movie
that you could argue to be positive so i
had fun with that i'm glad you all had
fun with that
and with the the duel of the fate script
star wars episode 9 duel of fate script
when that hit i had to revisit the
mirror universe
which people are like oh it's like a
fake movie that you're reviewing but
it's not really you know
it still is a script that i read so it's
like reviewing a book i suppose if i
ever reviewed a book it would probably
be like that you know you still see the
images in your head
you have the dialogue so it's not not
like i made the whole thing up the
script is out there pointies in 2020
there were a couple times a couple of
videos were things you know a little
more creative
kind of like october october i was like
all horror movies
granted i wanted to do them like five
days a week and
i really underestimated life things that
just happened
outside of youtube been doing this for
over 11 years now
i guess i haven't gotten used to that
but that was good i wanted to be a
werewolf i got werewolf gloves and
contacts the werewolf gloves sucked so i
returned those i was like i'll do
contacts contacts hurt my eyes
it feels like literally satan's [ __ ]
in your eyes it's like dude 2020 is
already hell
i don't need to feel hell in my eyes so
the contacts went away but the point is
in october it was just all horror movies
it was another borap movie that came out
i didn't even i was like no
all horror movies and yes for those of
you who caught it that intro is totally
from
altered beast i just kind of recreated
the mutation in altered beasts which i'd
love to say i planned it out but
i didn't it was tedious i had to go
through and
find a video every couple months or so
my hair was just a little longer find a
frame
in which i was more or less facing the
camera line it up and
you know it was tedious but it kind of
goes to what i've always done on my
channel it's like these
simple effects that end up being kind of
creative and i thought it was pretty
cool and to answer the question
yes this is actually before coveted
lockdown but on my review of the
invisible man people are like is there
an invisible you right there
so the entire video there's an invisible
me it's like 98
invisible and it's there from the
beginning of the video
up through the rating and then after the
rating i think i piss off also there's
this
i suppose i should explain that at first
you know you couldn't get your hair cut
because you couldn't lock down and all
that so it's like okay i guess i don't
get a haircut and then i got a trim when
they opened back up and then i was like
i just keep it growing because it's like
every time you think of 20 20
you'll see my face it's like a time
capsule i don't know i just i was like
if there's a year to just grow
everything out and see how it goes it's
this year
but also because people always do that
thing at the end of the year where it's
like oh me at the beginning of the year
me at the end of the year and it's like
you know the beginning is a picture of
smiggle and then the end is a picture of
gollum and you know
they do that with fictional characters
but i was like aha
i get to do it at the end of the year
with actually me like a picture of me
actually at the beginning of 2020 and me
actually at the end
nailed it i guess the joke's done
so now what a joke that i actually
haven't seen a lot of people doing this
year
oh that would have been a waste of time
i'll be honest with you like i
i could trim the beard i'll probably
keep the hair for a bit you know but
trim the beard to be a normal like i
wanted to braid it like a viking or
something you know i have the two on the
side or the one in the middle
that's just taking too long i figured if
i got to do it by the end of the year
sweet and if not well it just didn't
work out but first all right here we go
here we go
permission to come aboard i'll probably
trim the beard to be a normal beard keep
the hair
you know basically what i need to do to
keep that johnny silverhand cosplay
possibly going because if i don't get
those key under comments in the comment
section
what do i have all right this video
became much more indulgent than i meant
for it to it just i don't know
just figured looking back at 2020 and
you know
the not shitty things of 2020 that's fun
but again thank you all for keeping my
channel going in 2020
genuine thank you from the bottom of my
heart hopefully my channel gave you that
escapism that maybe you needed this year
i mean there was enough of a bus fire
coming at
everybody from all directions so it's a
very conscious effort it's been a
conscious effort for a while for my
channel to be that escapism just like no
no
i'm staying out of that i'm talking
movies and having fun
because maybe you need that so this year
that was extremely important to keep
that going
it'll probably be important next year
too as the logistics of this video are a
little different than other videos
instead of saying if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more i will
simply quote the great abraham lincoln
and saying be excellent to each other
and party on dudes
you